Kyrie it was the game was tied up with
over a minute left to play what did it
take to close out this game
uh
took not being soft honestly we'd be
coming out too soft sometimes and
basketball is meant to be played at a
high level high level intensity and our
fans will let us know it if we're not
playing hard enough so I appreciate that
and uh you know it just makes us want to
go harder really we want to we want to
take this to a championship run we got
to do the little things to win and that
includes doing everything every
possession Kyrie you had 30.7 assists 11
of 24 from the field what allowed you to
be so successful sounds like Kobe
numbers and Kyrie numbers right there 11
24 for a good night so I'll take it uh
you know and I'm glad that we got to do
it as a team uh we showed our resolve in
the third and fourth quarter and that's
what we got to do from the start of the
game but this feels good to get our
first home win and now we gotta get on
the road and you